these are the last pictures salim
nowetti sent his family before he died
earlier this month the sixteen-year-old
had leukemia but couldn't get treatment
in any hospital his family says the
delay in getting urgent medical
attention killed him
when salim went to the hospital they
refused to admit him saying the
palestinian authority has not paid its
debts but three other people have been
admitted i am sure they had better
connections and managed to get
themselves in public hospitals do not
provide cancer treatment so the
government transfers patients to private
hospitals or abroad
salim nowetti didn't get a transfer
in a news conference the health ministry
admitted medical workers failed to act
in time
in 2016 president mahmoud abbas
announced the building of a new cancer
hospital to treat the growing number of
patients
this is the land where the hospital was
supposed to be built but six years later
many activists have been asking
where's the hospital and they're
accusing palestinian officials of
stealing the money dedicated to building
it
prime minister mohammad stayed has said
donations has only covered a small part
of the overall budget of 160 million
dollars and that the plans have been put
on hold
but many have said that this shows how
little transparency there is between the
palestinians and the authority
a recent poll shows that 63 percent of
palestinians think there is corruption
in public institutions but people are
often too scared to report it
even though there's a system to protect
whistleblowers maruwa farah says she
wasn't protected
she's been at home for the past two
years after being fired from her job for
reporting nepotism and abuse of power at
work
i'm now being accused of slander and i'm
fighting it in court no one is hiring me
because they think i'm a troublemaker
palestinians have seen the president's
power expand at the expense of the
legislature and judiciary
we have a weak rule of law the
president's office has been getting more
authority this has led to more decisions
that benefit certain officials and
powerful circles around the president
even when some corruption allegations
are investigated perpetrators are rarely
held accountable critics say that
without the political will to fight
corruption efforts to combat the problem
will remain limited nida ibrahim
al-jazeera the occupied west bank